[Applause]
a psychedelic means that
you're consuming a substance that the
the main ingredient that's active in the
brain
is foreign to the brain so mushrooms are
organic right but still psilocybin is a
psychedelic because it's foreign to the
brain
simultaneously lsd is chemical man-made
and it's
foreign to the brain they classify uh
ayahuasca in something called in
theogenics
right and theogen means that the active
ingredient is inside of the system
already
so but that doesn't mean you can't have
a problem
right smoke too much deep look here's
the problem with psychedelics right you
see people
so i said i'd do an average of like 150
ayahuasca ceremonies
a year right so if you took mushrooms
try taking mushrooms 150 times in a year
right
you're not gonna make it you know what i
mean you're gonna be
you know naked with the trees you're a
burning man year round we're going to be
chasing burning man all year right
like a [ __ ] dog with a fire hydrant
just looking for the next hippie
festival
right you take mushrooms 150 times in a
year i mean take a lsd
yeah you're a kid yeah you're done okay
you can't un-fry a steak that's the
brain
that's why you can't pay me to take a
drug you can't
pay me to take lsd because it's not like
oh but omar
it's the purest i mean i know a lot of
people man and that
omar it's the purest lsd like you don't
understand
i don't want to understand i don't need
to understand
because i have no purpose why would i
take this what am i
what is lsd going to give me that i have
not
already experienced or do not have the
possibility of experiencing
with like there's no such thing that's
why it's the problem with our world
today as you're
going into it it's great i'm glad you
opened this up there's no such thing as
an lsd shaman
right like there's no there's no you're
on your journey
there's no yeah there's no dmt shaman
yes
yes regardless of what shaman and tulum
tells you regardless of what popular
people say yes
it's [ __ ] a shaman is somebody who
utilizes
vibration tools whether the voice
whether
flutes drums they use tools to bombard
the five sensorial three-dimensional
reality
in the fourth dimension of vibration
right vibration
to awaken the sixth sense to take you
outside of your own thoughts
into your own sixth sense right that's
that spiritual journey
now people consume psychedelics and
medicines of different kinds
to go into those spaces but the shaman
is someone who works with spirit
and there's no such thing as lsd spirit
what's the spirit of lsd it's literally
a mind [ __ ]
right and so like what's the goal to
trip out of your mind
that's the fear so what's the point you
know what i mean it's like the
definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
again expecting a different result but
at the same time
the point of a trip is to get out of
your mind but that's the fear
that's the ultimate fear to fry your
brain
and never be able to come back
schizophrenia is someone who's stuck
in between multiple dimensions i would
serve medicine to that person and fix
them
there's another medicine by the way that
i don't work with called
toei and i'm not promoting this any of
this stuff i'm saying look into this
stuff
this medicine is known for fixing
bipolar disorder
uh schizophrenia it's a it's a leaf
remember in alice in wonderland
where she's going down the rabbit hole
right she's following the right white
rabbit and
all she had to do was just turn around
stop chasing the rabbit
and at one point when she goes in with
the flowers and the ones like alice
stop you're going the wrong way they go
what i am like don't listen to her
that's that's bergman's she's always
fibbing that flower that beaut
that's that's toei
right and i would never serve someone
this because it's serious it's even more
it's like the most psychoactive like
plant flower
on the earth but i know like grand
maestros like two like
you know 50 years oh there would bring
bring
it in you know watch the brain surgeon
get to work but yeah and there's i know
i have seen at least a dozen and i know
of
you know dozens of people who have had
certain situations
that they get fixed to that so anything
that can be created
through you know we we create drugs to
fix
problems but those problems were created
by drugs we're going further and further
away from nature
and finding more drugs to fix the
problem right but mother nature
can fix anything that are for the
children on the earth so it's like
the idea that there's not a plant yep to
fix
fill in the blank is crazy so so how do
i balance
my desperation
to find some sort of cure for my brother
who i love
more than anything in the world and
kind of like fact-checking and
understanding this experience
that he could potentially go through i
mean i guess at this point there's
little to lose right because we've tried
these different drugs and it doesn't
really help him but like
i'm only willing to go down this path
because of my desperation but the drugs
that they're using are to trying to make
him
normal and be able to operate in society
trying to make you operate make it make
him a lemming
the goal is let him try to live a normal
life yes right
yeah and the problem is is that the the
program
in the mind is is scrambled yes right
and so they're trying to give them pills
to unscramble that
yes right but that's not gonna
necessarily work because the soul like
the when there's a will there's a way
right like it's gonna have to fix from
within
that's the problem with psychedelic
especially with like lsd
yeah the problem with people smoking
well if i smoke dmt
it's a quicker way than drinking
ayahuasca yeah the
the notion is all the tech people oh
it's 15 minutes why would you need this
experience yeah and it's like there is
not it's not the same thing like
there is a if you think [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
sure but there is a difference between
having like tantric sex with a
victoria's secret model for four hours
and having sex with a prostitute in
bogota for 15 minutes
yes okay but if if it's just [ __ ]
then it's the same thing and that's the
difference between ayahuasca and dmt
there's there's a difference in that and
the thing is when
people start chasing the dragon they're
to get burned he was chasing it man
that's the problem and it's [ __ ]
that's the problem because you're taking
the idea of taking something
what is it that people chase what is it
that they're going after
that's what i'm trying to understand
depends there's great look there are
people who are crazy
yeah crazy exists too that's crazy you
know like what's the point of playing
russian roulette
what's the best thing that happens you
don't die what's the worst thing that
happens you die
yeah like sign don't sign me up for that
but there are people who like
you know there's a bunch of crazy
[ __ ] that'll get together and
be like let's play russian roulette
and maybe seven people like [ __ ] no but
two guys are like i'll do it
yeah and i mean those two crazy people
and that's the problem like
chasing the dragon then you want to
wonder what happens when you get burned
but when you're burned you can't you're
going to have the scar yeah you can't
unburn
you know and so the so lsd like imagine
you're going to take something that's
going to
scramble up your brain that costs five
dollars
that's sounds crazy man yeah
it's like five dollars man like that's
nuts you know and if you watch these old
hippies that were
you know growing up like oh man i'm
they're gone
you know you see these mushroom like you
know the guys you haven't experienced
that with ayahuasca
you haven't haven't it's not going to
happen i become sharper
because i i was reading a little but i
don't [ __ ] around brother
yeah i don't i'm i don't like i don't
like
i don't take mushrooms for fun survival
on the weekend i don't
drink alcohol you live this life yeah
man i'm i
yeah i'm a hundred percent you know like
i'm yeah i'm 100
going this way the um
i read i was listening to a podcast
actually
and one of the guys on the podcast said
that
ayahuasca is different from most
[Music]
drugs medicines in that
the more you take it the stronger it
becomes
why well i almost know my answer but
i was gonna say i saw you figure it out
yeah
your body let me see if this is the
answer your body
gets desensitized to things it's not
supposed to consume
so in other words it says who well no no
like i mean like
like for example if i drink alcohol my
body knows that it's not that good
so my body starts to go okay we gotta
build up some tolerance to this [ __ ]
you shouldn't be doing this and if you
drink too much your body says get rid of
it now
so you don't die right um
whereas maybe with ayahuasca assuming
that it is something that we're supposed
to ingest or it is natural
your body doesn't build up that
tolerance because it doesn't want to
you become more sensitive yeah so it's
almost allowing you
or you're allowing or you've built up
trust and you're allowing it
yeah so is are there anything is there
anything else like that can you think of
another substance like it doesn't even
have to be something that takes you on a
journey like
it's water or something no no we build
tolerances to everything
we we build tolerances everything
caffeine
water well why do you drink more you
need more yeah so pretty much everything
else
except for ayahuasca because of the
because of what we're talking about
ultimately
like we're talking about this we're
talking about us
assault like the spiritual journey the
more we get into
look the more you get in tune with your
body through working out
right yeah the one mile doesn't go as
far right
now let's say you start running like
look i'm gonna start running
and so you start off with a mile after
hopefully like just a couple weeks
one miles like you know break a sweat
now you do two now you do five
right yeah yeah but it's not that you
need to do more miles it's that you're
able you've conditioned your body to go
deeper in the journey
of running